virtual reality it's a really big thing
at e3 but so it was augmented reality
with microsoft's hololens i'm incredibly
jealous because my buddy Rob over here
you got to use the freaking thing yeah
like it was Incredibles you know just to
kind of get into oculus rift we both
tried it we've had the conversation
before about sitting down and use a
controller and having your brain kind of
battle real life and then the game
itself right so in that case I've gone
motion sickness before but hololens
my god I will say a hundred percent felt
so natural yeah I mean because
essentially it's not trying to replace
everything in your surroundings right
what it's doing is from what I
understand projecting things that when
you're looking at them in the headset
makes it look like it's part of your
actual environment right so you don't
have that huge disconnect which is a
pretty hard thing to make work really
well right yeah so it was really cool I
could just kind of go over what I saw
exactly so it was basically the
beginning of a Halo game right they put
it on by way the hololens itself fits
snug natural not heavy at all Wireless
it felt great it you know I'm wearing
glasses basically yeah so they had me
sitting down and they go okay like you
know just like in Halo games it's like
okay sir looking over here look over
here calibrate and you're doing it and
right away it's like oh my god I'm I'm
innovative I'm in a video game okay but
describe to me the elements that are in
that scene because I can understand you
know moving your head to relate to
something but you know what what are the
actual things that you're seeing how
does it appear within your environment
it's totally like a Hut so basically
thing from me they had a wall just like
I imagine like a blackboard yeah and
what I'm seeing is basically each corner
of the blackboard was like a little dot
blue diamond you know with cute little
graphics around it and every time I
looked at it so the hot ones also has
like a pinpoint crosshair so whatever
activity the crop my crosshair is
touching choose the graphic space to
change and turn on so I was doing I hit
four corners yeah and they're like okay
get up and walk down the hallway so
again this is Wireless so you're just in
the moment I literally felt I was in a
video game because I stand up I looked
down the hallway and then there's the
Waypoint
like classic hallo here's your Waypoint
walk - sure enough to walk down the hall
and it's just there sitting you know
perfectly there wasn't any glitching to
it it was freakin perfect so I mean it
sound like what you're telling me is
that what it looks like during
Microsoft's presentations is pretty
indicative of what you experienced dude
like 1% I mean I didn't feel any like
detraction like it was perfect so yeah I
mean again you walk to the hit at the
point and you walk down and then there's
a guy there oh by the way everyone who
was working at 343 work what they're
wearing white flat coats and ice and
they of course we're saying Spartan come
over here so I am I am lock I am Master
Chief whatever you want to call it
anyways so I get to a point I have to
make my left Waypoint and then they say
look over here and what again was just
kind of like a blackboard so I'm not
also assuming that you know these
blackboards that were in real life yeah
are probably just references for this
hololens to base office so I'm looking
at it and then cue the hololens graphic
and it opens up and now i'm looking
through a window and it's a hanger with
a pelican taking off and again like i'm
in real life i'm up like this to the
wall yeah yeah but I'm looking around in
in your CSS you're seeing volume in
there and all this hanger I mean it felt
freakin amazing and then again okay come
over here and then everyone Huddle's
around like a classic circular table
diagram yeah and that's when they just
go to town and they show you the
infinity shift from Halo 4 spinning and
again the crosshair comes into fact
where I'm looking at the engines of the
ship and a little graphic pops up and in
highlights and says these are the ion
engines or what not and then they give
me a preview of life ok Spartan you're
going in here here's our world and this
is on the table it opens up in a world
comes up and you dive in and they start
dissecting you know these are the three
bases and just give me a rundown on the
new game-mode war zone and again like
you're getting up really close and it's
like looks great it's like HD like
detail texture and everything
so actually wheat and I talk to other
people who I saw with the only gripe as
of now is that your peripheral is like
this so what I am
that is a hologram yeah he's like this
basically okay so the closer I get the
hologram basically bleeds off and that's
whatever is not shown here and that's
where you're kind of like alright I mean
it's it's it's it's drifting away I mean
I'm not it's it wasn't like a deal
breaker but again you're just like okay
there is a limit to this well the
technology is still pretty early right
but it sounds like you're really
impressed hololens and this exciting
stuff there's a lot of exciting stuff
coming out of three of III of course
stay tuned a gamespot.com c-more this
guy maybe some of me if you're lucky
take care bye